OKAY, WE ARE HERE WITH
EVERYBODY, ESTABLISHING A QUORUM
. SO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING. AND WELCOME. WE
HAVE SIX MEASURES ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY. BUT BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL, LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BLAKE.
SPEER, PRESENT. SPEER, PRESENT.
ONE HERE, ONE HERE. ALLEN.
MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR. HERE.
NEWMAN. HERE. NEWMAN. HERE
PORTANTINO. UMBERG. OKAY. WE
HAVE ONE VOTE ONLY ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA, AND IT IS ACA SIX, ACA
SIX WAS HEARD AND FAILED IN THE
SENATE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE ON
SEPTEMBER 11TH, 2023.
RECONSIDERATION WAS GRANTED
UNANIMOUSLY. THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT HAS NOT BEEN FURTHER
AMENDED. WE WILL HAVE A
RECONSIDERATION VOTE TODAY,
WHICH WILL BE VOTE ONLY PER THE
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE
SENATE FOR ALL LEGISLATIVE
MEASURES WITH NO AMENDMENTS AND
NOTICED AS VOTE ONLY. THERE WILL
BE NO AUTHOR STATEMENT. THERE
WILL BE NO WITNESS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THERE
WILL BE NO DISCUSSION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE WILL BE
A VOTE. SO I WILL NOW ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ON ACA SIX. IS THERE A
MOTION? OKAY. THERE IS A MOTION
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BLAKE SPEER. ONE ALLEN MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN NØ NEWMAN NÓ
PORTANTINO UMBERG. IT IS ONE ONE
AND IT WILL BE HELD ON CALL.
GREAT. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA HERE. PERFECT TIMING.
WE'RE READY FOR YOU. SO OUR NEXT
ITEM WILL BE AB 2041 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. AND WHEN YOU ARE
PREPARED, YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO START OFF, I INTRODUCED AB
2041. IN RESPONSE TO THE
ALARMING INCREASE IN POLITICAL
VIOLENCE DIRECTED TOWARDS
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND CANDIDATES
FOR OFFICE AS PUBLIC SERVANTS,
THERE IS MUCH WE HUMBLY AND
WILLINGLY SACRIFICE TO SERVE,
INCLUDING SPENDING TIME WITH OUR
FAMILY AND MAINTAINING OUR
PRIVACY. HOWEVER THE ONE THING
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SACRIFICE
IS OUR SENSE OF SAFETY, OUR
SAFETY OF THE FAMILIES THAT
SUPPORT US AND THOSE WHO WORK
CLOSELY WITH US. UNFORTUNATELY,
WE HAVE SEEN A RISE IN THREATS
AGAINST CANDIDATES AND PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, ESPECIALLY WOMEN, AND
HARASSMENT OF STAFF SERVING OUR
CONSTITUENTS. A 2023 STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S LIST FOUND 42% OF WOMEN
ENCOUNTERED STALKING AT LEAST
ONCE WHILE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, WITH ALMOST 1 IN 5
EXPERIENCING IT FREQUENTLY OR
VERY FREQUENTLY. THIS RATE IS 15
TIMES HIGHER THAN THAT REPORTED
BY MEN. THIS DISPARITY IS MORE
PRONOUNCED AMONG WOMEN OF COLOR,
WHICH WE NEARLY WAS NEARLY 55,
AND LGBTQ PLUS WOMEN, WHICH WAS
FOUND TO BE NEARLY 53. AB 2041
AIMS TO PROTECT CANDIDATES,
ELECTED OFFICIALS, THEIR
FAMILIES AND STAFF BY
AUTHORIZING PERSONAL SECURITY AS
A CAMPAIGN EXPENSE AND EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR SECURITY IN
ADDITION, IT ELIMINATES THE
$5,000 LIFETIME CAP ON SECURITY
EXPENSES USING CAMPAIGN FUNDS,
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN ADJUSTED FOR
30 YEARS. LASTLY, AB 2041
REMOVES THE REQUIREMENT FOR A
VERIFIED THREAT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO REIMBURSE A
SECURITY EXPENSE. THIS IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF AB 37, WHICH,
WITH CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
REGARDING WHAT CAN BE CONSIDERED
A SECURITY EXPENSE, ALONG WITH
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE AROUND THE
REPORTING THE EXPENSES TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY. WE HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY, EXTENSIVELY ON THIS
BILL LANGUAGE WITH THE FPPC
CANDIDATE SECURITY IS A
NONPARTISAN ISSUE AND HAS
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AUDREY WILL BE SHARING
TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY TODD
SPITZER. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AUDREY RITECHECK FROM
CRUZ STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT. IS YOUR
MICROPHONE ON? OKAY, THERE WE
GO. OKAY. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
AUDREY RITECHECK FROM CRUZ
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
TODD SPITZER. I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT AB 2041 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND THANKING HER
FOR BRINGING THIS MUCH NEEDED
LEGISLATION FORWARD AND WORKING
ON THE SUPPORT WE HAD FOR AB 37
LAST YEAR. THIS BILL PROVIDES
NECESSARY CHANGES IN LAW TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN LAWS, CAMPAIGNS CAN PAY
FOR IN-HOME OR OFFICE SECURITY
EXPENSES, BUT THAT IS LIMITED
SOLELY FOR THE PROTECTION OF THE
CANDIDATE OR ELECTED OFFICIAL.
ONCE THE THREAT HAS BEEN
VERIFIED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
THERE'S ALSO A $5,000 LIFETIME
CAP ON CAMPAIGN SECURITY
EXPENDITURES THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION OR THE
COST OF LIVING. THE CAP NEEDS TO
BE UPDATED TO REFLECT THE
CURRENT COST MARKET FOR HOME
ALARM SYSTEMS AND OTHER SECURITY
PROTECTION MEASURES, WHICH CAN
EASILY EXCEED THE CURRENT CAP.
THE PROCESS IS TRANSPARENT, AND
ALL OF THESE SECURITY EXPENSES
ARE REPORTED ON THE APPROPRIATE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE FORMS OF THE
CANDIDATE OR OFFICE HOLDER. AS
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL FOR OVER TWO
DECADES, DE SPITZER AND HIS
FAMILY HAVE EXPERIENCED NUMEROUS
CONCERNING THREATS, INCLUDING A
STALKER THAT HAS SHOWN UP TO HIS
HOME MULTIPLE TIMES THROUGHOUT
HIS CAREER. HE HAS HAD TO
IMPLEMENT A MYRIAD OF NECESSARY
SECURITY PROTECTIONS THAT FAR
EXCEED THE CAP. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR, AND FOR THESE REASONS,
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2041 AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM? YOU MAY
STEP FORWARD. GOOD MORNING,
JOHNNY PINA WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON. MOVE ON TO
LEAD WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
IF THERE ARE ANY, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. OKAY. WE DO NOT SEE
ANY. WHAT ABOUT, OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM? OKAY NOT
SEEING ANY. I THANK THE AUTHOR
AND, THE SUPPORT WITNESS FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DISCUSSION
OF MEMBERS IS SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHORS. GLADYS, SUPPORT THE
BILL. I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THOUGH. SO WITH RESPECT, TO THE
END OF SOMEONE'S TERM WHERE
THERE MAY STILL BE POLITICAL
FUNDS LEFT, DOES THE BILL. I
DIDN'T SEE ANY LANGUAGE. DOES
THE BILL PROVIDE FOR THE
EXTENSION OF SECURITY, EVEN
WHILE SOMEBODY MIGHT NOT BE IN
OFFICE? THEY MIGHT STILL NEED
IT, THERE IS A CLAUSE IN THE
BILL THAT ALLOWS FOR THE ACTUAL,
KIND OF VERIFICATION OF THE
NEEDING OF THAT EQUIPMENT, BUT
IT UPON THE END OF ONE'S TERM,
AFTER A YEAR FOR THE TANGIBLE
SECURITY EXPENSES, YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO REIMBURSE YOUR THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE COST OF THE
TANGIBLE SECURITY THAT YOU'VE
EQUIPMENT THAT YOU'VE BEEN
THERE. SO IF SOMEBODY'S NOT IN
OFFICE, THEY THEN THEY THEN
ASSUME ESSENTIALLY, YES, EVEN IF
THEIR CAMPAIGN FUNDS LEFT OVER,
THAT MIGHT BE USED FOR THAT
PURPOSE. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S VERIFIED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. RIGHT. THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY IT COULD CONTINUE. SO
IF THERE WAS AN ACTIVE THREAT
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT VERIFIED,
THEN YOU COULD KEEP IT BEYOND
THE TERM. OKAY. SO GOT IT. SO
OTHERWISE IT'S DUE WITHIN ONE
YEAR OKAY. THAT MAKES SENSE
OKAY. IT MAKES GOOD SENSE. AND I
WILL ALSO SAY TO THE WITNESS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. SO I
WAS THE TARGET OF A CREDIBLE
THREAT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE DA'S
ACTIVE PARTICIPATION AND CONCERN
IN THAT CASE, WHICH WAS RESOLVED
PROPERLY. SO THANK YOU. GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. DID YOU WANT
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS? OKAY. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL AS
WELL. I WANTED TO JUST FOLLOW UP
ON THE QUESTION THAT MY
COLLEAGUE ASKED. SO IF THERE'S,
PERSONAL SECURITY EQUIPMENT
THAT'S IN THAT YOU HAVE
INSTALLED IN YOUR HOUSE LIKE AN
ALARM SYSTEM, AND YOU WOULD BE
PAYING FOR IT IN A MONTHLY BASIS
FROM YOUR CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT, AND
THEN YOU'RE NO LONGER IN OFFICE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REIMBURSE THE
CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT FOR THE ACTUAL
COST OF THAT EQUIPMENT. IS THAT
WHAT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE TO REIMBURSE THE
CAMPAIGN FOR THE COST OF THE
EQUIPMENT, BUT THEN YOU WOULD
TAKE ON THE EXPENSE OF AFTER A
YEAR, BUT THEN YOU WOULD TAKE ON
THE EXPENSE OF THE SUBSCRIPTION
THÀNH, IF YOU WILL, AS A
PERSONAL EXPENSE. OKAY. THAT I
MEAN, IT SEEMS UNNECESSARY TO ME
THAT SOMEONE WOULD HAVE TO
REIMBURSE THE CAMPAIGN FOR THE
COST OF THE EQUIPMENT. WAS THAT
AN AMENDMENT YOU WERE FORCED TO
TAKE IN A COMMITTEE OR, THAT WAS
, AFTER MANY ROUNDS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FPPC Kò
WHAT THEY FELT THE MOST
COMFORTABLE WITH, I SEE, OKAY,
BECAUSE IF A, IF A CANDIDATE HAS
OR SOMEONE IN OFFICE BUYS LIKE
MATERIAL FOR A PICNIC OR
SOMETHING, THEY'RE NOT RETURNING
THAT THOSE SHARES AND THINGS
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO PAY. I
MEAN, IT'S ESSENTIALLY
CONSIDERED LIKE CONSUMED. I
WHILE I AGREE WITH YOU, THE FPPC
WAS VERY CLEAR ON NEEDING TO
ENSURE THE UTMOST RESPONSIBILITY
WAS, TAKEN IN THE USE OF
SECURITY DEVICES FOR A CANDIDATE
OR, AND ELECTED OFFICIALS. OKAY,
OKAY, I UNDERSTAND, THANK YOU.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT AND IMPORTANT BILL.
AND IT'S SO TO ME, IT'S SO CLEAR
THAT THIS IS A THREAT THAT IS
PARTICULAR TO BEING IN OFFICE OR
TO BEING A CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE,
BUT BEING SERVING IN OFFICE. AND
YOU HEAR THE STORIES, I MEAN, AT
EVERY LEVEL, AND SO I'M GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE UPDATING A 30 YEAR
OLD LAW AND, AND ALSO JUST
RECOGNIZING THE REALITY OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO SERVE TODAY. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE, VOTE. THANK YOU. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
UMBERG OR I'M SORRY, FROM
SENATOR NEWMAN. I'M SORRY,
ORANGE COUNTY, I WAS THINKING I
WAS THINKING ABOUT WHERE IS HE?
FROM SENATOR, FROM SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
BLAKESPEAR. AYE SHAKESPEARE.
AYE. WHEN ALAN MENGIBAR. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN.
AYE PORTANTINO. UMBERG. IT IS
THREE ZERO, AND WE WILL KEEP IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU FOR RUSHING
OVER HERE. WE APPRECIATE IT. SO
NOW WE COULD TAKE UP OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
ARE THREE ITEMS A, B 2001 A, B
2582 AND A B 3197. WOULD ANY
MEMBER LIKE TO PULL ANY ITEM
FROM CONSENT? OKAY OKAY. WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL. CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS BLAKE SPEAR I
BLAKE SPEAR I ONE ALLEN MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO I UMBERG
. ONE CALL OKAY. IT IS FOUR ZERO
AND WE WILL KEEP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL. SO THE NEXT
AND ONLY REMAINING ITEM IS FROM
SENATOR ALLEN, BUT WE COULD LIFT
THE CALL FOR SENATOR PORTENTINO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE US TO DO THAT
NOW. OKAY, LET'S LIFT THE CALL.
LIFTING CALL AND FILE ITEM ONE
AC SIX. MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 1. LAKE
SPEAR ONE. ALLEN PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I UMBERG. TWO ONE.
NOW IT'S TWO ONE. WE WILL KEEP
IT ON CALL. LET'S LET'S JUST LET
HIM VOTE ON THE OTHER THINGS
REALLY QUICK, JUST IN CASE MAN
WALKS IN LIFTING CALL AND FILE
ITEM FOUR AB 2041. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE WHEN
ALLEN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
UMBERG. OKAY, WELL, LET'S, MOVE
ON OR SORRY, IT'S FOUR ZERO AND
WE WILL KEEP IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. SO NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO
MEASURE SCR 157 FROM ALLEN. AND
IT WILL PRESENTED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
OKAY, GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS I AM HAPPY TO PRESENT
SCR 157 ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ALLEN, WHICH WILL WITHDRAW SCA
TWO FROM THE NOVEMBER BALLOT,
ARTICLE 34 OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WAS ADDED IN 1950,
EXPLICITLY TO PROHIBIT THE
DEVELOPMENT, CONSTRUCTION OR
ACQUISITION OF LOW RENT HOUSING
PROJECTS BY ANY GOVERNMENT
ENTITY UNTIL SUCH PROJECTS WERE
APPROVED BY LOCAL VOTERS.
BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
QUICKLY IS A PRIORITY, AND
SENATOR ALLEN INTRODUCED SCA TWO
TO PUT THE REPEAL OF ARTICLE 34
ON THE BALLOT AS ONE OF A HOST
OF EFFORTS TO HELP ADDRESS THE
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA, LAST YEAR, SENATOR
ALLEN ALSO AUTHORED SB 469,
WHICH SUBSTANTIALLY ADDRESSES
SOME OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW ARTICLE 34
MIGHT BE IMPACTING HOUSING
PRODUCTION ACROSS THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE THERE IS ENOUGH PUBLIC
SUPPORT FOR REPEALING ARTICLE 34
AT THE PRESENT TIME ON THE
BALLOT, THERE ARE ROUGHLY A
DOZEN OTHER MEASURES THAT WILL
BE GOING ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT,
AND REACHING VOTERS DURING THAT
TIME AND GETTING THEIR ATTENTION
WILL BE BOTH DIFFICULT AND
PROSPECTIVELY EXPENSIVE, ARTICLE
34 SHOULD BE REPEALED FROM THE
CONSTITUTION, BUT THE TIMING OF
THIS MEASURE IS SUBOPTIMAL,
GIVEN THE CURRENT SITUATION OR
THE EXPECTED SITUATION ON THE
NEXT BALLOT. NOW, WITHOUT AN
URGENT NEED, AND WITH THE MANY
COMPETING BALLOT PRIORITIES, IT
IS SENATOR ALLEN'S BELIEF THAT
IT WOULD BE BEST TO PULL SCA TWO
FROM THE BALLOT, RATHER THAN
PROSPECTIVE WASTE TIME, EFFORT,
AND RESOURCES ON A MEASURE THAT
MAY NOT PASS AT THIS POINT, BUT
SHOULD, ESPECIALLY GIVEN SUPPORT
AND SOME SPACE BE MORE LIKELY TO
PASS ON A SUBSEQUENT BALLOT? SCR
157 WOULD WITHDRAW SCA TWO FROM
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
BEST TIME TO PUT THE QUESTION
BEFORE VOTERS TO ONCE AGAIN TRY
TO REPEAL ARTICLE 34, WHICH IS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA, AND THE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLEN, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. GREAT
JOB. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? I DO
NOT, OKAY. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KARIM DRISSI,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS, HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SCR 157,
WHILE WE DO SUPPORT SCA TWO,
WHICH IS CURRENTLY PENDING ON
THE BALLOT, WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT IS A VERY CROWDED
INITIATIVE, FIELD, AND AS A
RESULT, IT WILL BE EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING TO PROPERLY
COMMUNICATE WITH VOTERS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THEY MAKE THE
MOST INFORMED DECISION POSSIBLE.
AS A RESULT, WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SCA, EXCUSE ME, SCR 157, AND
REQUEST YOUR. I VOTE HERE TODAY
AND WE WISH TO SINCERELY THANK
BOTH, SENATOR ALLEN AND SENATOR
WIENER FOR THEIR EFFORTS ON SCA
TWO, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH THEM AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON FUTURE ARTICLE 34
REPEAL EFFORTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY A LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YES ARE
THERE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ARE THERE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR STATEMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS? OKAY. SENATOR MENGIBAR
IS MOVING THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE? THANK YOU.
OKAY. AND I WILL JUST SAY THAT I
ALSO WANT TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT ARTICLE 34 SHOULD BE
REPEALED. AND I HOPE THAT WE DO
DO THAT AT SOME POINT, BECAUSE
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN LIVE INSIDE
INSTEAD OF OUTSIDE, AND I'M WAS,
DISAPPOINTED WHEN THIS WAS BEING
PULLED. BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
REASONING, AND I HOPE THAT WE DO
GET BACK TO IT. SO, WITH THAT,
THERE IS A MOTION ON SCR 157,
AND IT IS Dð PASS BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. SO ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
BREAKSPEAR I LARKSPUR I WHEN
ALAN MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NEWMAN
I NEWMAN I PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO I UMBERG I UMBERG I.
IT'S FIVE ZERO. IT'S ON CALL AND
WE COULD LIFT THE CALL FOR
SENATOR UMBERG. LIFTING CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE AK SIX. MOTION IS
BE ADOPTED AND REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ONE BLAKESPEAR ONE. ALAN
UMBERG. IT'S TWO ONE ON CALL.
AND LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON ALL
ITEMS FOR SENATOR UMBERG LIFTING
CALL ON FILE ITEM FOUR AB 2041.
MOTION IS Dð PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE
WHEN ALAN UMBERG Ã UMBERG I.
IT'S 571 CALLS. IT'S FIVE ZERO.
WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL LIFTING
CALL ON CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
INCLUDE AB 2001, AB 2582 AND AB
3197. CURRENT VOTE IS 5000.
SORRY. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE ONE ALAN
UMBERG UMBERG AYE FIVE ZERO ON
CALL. IT'S FIVE ZERO. WE WILL
KEEP IT ON CALL. OKAY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR UMBERG. GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANKS FOR STOPPING BY. SO
WE WILL NOW Þ. I WAS GOING TO
SAY, IF YOU WANT.
SO WE WILL NOW GO INTO A BRIEF
RECESS.
OKAY. THE SENATE ELECTIONS IS
BACK IN ORDER, AND WE ARE
LIFTING THE CALL ON ALL ITEMS
FOR SENATOR NGUYEN LIFTING. CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE AC SIX. MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED AND REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ONE. LAKESPUR. WHEN ALAN
UMBERG STILL TWO ONE ON CALL. IT
IS STILL TWO ONE ON CALL LIFTING
CALL ON FILE. ITEM FOUR AB 2041.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE WHEN
I WHEN I ALAN 601 CALL SIX ZERO.
WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL.
APOLOGIES GOING BACK TO FILE
ITEM TWO SCR 157. MOTION IS Dð.
PASS CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTED AYE ONE ALAN 501
CALL. STILL IT'S FIVE ZERO. WE
WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL. LIFTING
CALL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEMS INCLUDE AB 2001, AB 2582
AND AB 3197. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE ONE
ONE EYE ALAN 6060. WE WILL KEEP
THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU. I WAS TRYING TO
EXPAND. WE WILL GO BACK INTO A
RECESS, BUT WE'LL COME OUT
SHORTLY.
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IS NOW BACK
IN SESSION AND WE WILL BE
LIFTING THE CALL ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS IN A SHORT
SECOND. HERE. OKAY, THE CALL IS
LIFTED, SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WILL COME
BACK IN 60S. THIS JUST SHOWS.
I'VE BEEN LISTENING TO THIS.
HERE WE GO. SORRY LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE AC SIX. MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED AND REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATION AS CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ONE LAKESPUR ONE. ALLEN
UMBERG 221. THE MEASURE FAILS.
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM TWO
SCR 157. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. CHAIR
VOTED AYE ONE ALLEN Ã ALLEN
I60. PASSES IT'S SIX ZERO. IT
PASSES LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM
FOUR AB 2041. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED AYE. ALLEN I ALLEN I
7070. IT PASSES LIFTING CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEMS
INCLUDE AB 2001, AB 2582 AND AB
3197. CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO.
CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTED I ALLEN, I ALLEN I 7070.
IT PASSES SEVEN OKAY OKAY. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS IS NOW ADJOURNED.
HUSING FRAWLEY'S. SENATOR DAHLE.